[Musique]
la nuit des musées permet aux visiteurs
de découvrir ou redécouvrir leurs lieux
culturels préféré dans une ambiance
nocturne et dans les yvelines les idées
ne manquent pas pour cette 18e édition
de la nuit des musées nous avons choisi
deux
dédié une animation au jeune public sur
le parvis du musée jusqu'à l'entrée du
château de l'églantine les enfants vont
pouvoir réaliser à la craie des motifs
de toiles de juillet en s'inspirant de
motifs qui ont le camp leur proposera en
un an ce médiatrice qui va animer les
accueillir
à quelques pas la maison léon blum se
prépare également à accueillir le public
cette année donc nous avons
effectivement en partenariat avec le
conservatoire
donc verser grand parc conservateur de
musique donc nous avons monté donc un
projet effectivement pour que des élèves
donc sous l'égide sous la responsabilité
de leurs professeurs vêtements viennent
donc faire de l'animation musicale d'une
part dans le parc avec des cuivres et
puis dans la maison donc avec d'une part
un quatuor donc à cordes et pénalement
eu des chants lyriques après une période
compliquée les lieux culturels sont
ravis de pouvoir organiser et repartager
des événements avec le public
c'est plus qu'un joueur c'est une
véritable respiration déjà pour l'équipe
du musée qui est qui n'a pas cessé de
travailler enfin dans la période du coc
vide car un musée be1 même quand il est
fermé c'est une joie à plaisir que que
nous redécouvrons ou en quelque sorte et
nous étions effectivement de jeu pas
dire de reconquérir parce qu'on n'a
jamais perdu public sauf que c'est celui
ci qui a été privée de cet échange donc
c'est un renouveau donc une renaissance
effectivement je dirais de la culture a
joui d'autres animations sont prévues
dans les yvelines le palais du roi de
rome à rambouillet organise un escape
game le domaine royal de marly fera une
visite en musique et en danse pour vous
plonger au temps de louis xiv et les
plus jeunes pourront également
construire leur propre bateau au musée
de la batellerie à conflans